[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's actually a major health crisis
today in terms of the shortage of organs
the fact is that we're living longer
Medicine has done a much better job
making us live longer and the problem is
as we age our organs tend to fail more
and so currently they're not enough
organs to go around in fact in the last
ten years a number of patients require
an organ has doubled well in the same
time the actual number of transplants
has barely gone up so there's now a
public health crisis so that's where
this field comes in that we call the
field of regenerative medicine it really
involves many different areas you can
use actually scaffolds biomaterials
they're like the piece of your blouse or
your shirt but specific materials you
can actually implant in patients and
they will do well and help you
regenerate or we can use cells alone
either your very own cells or different
stem cell populations or we can use both
we can use actually biomaterials and the
cells together and that's where the
field is today but it's actually not a
new field interestingly this is a book
that was published back in 1938 it's
titled a culture of organs the first
author Alexis Carrel and Nobel Prize
winner he actually devised some of the
same technologies used today for
suturing blood vessels and some of the
blood vessel grafts were used today were
actually designed by Alexis but I want
you to note his co-author Charles
Lindbergh that's the same Charles
Lindbergh who actually spend the rest of
his life working with Alexis at the
Rockefeller Institute in New York in the
area of the culture of organs so the
fields been around for so long why so
field clinical advances and that really
has to do to many different challenges
but if I were to point to three
challenges the first one is actually the
design of materials that could go in
your body and do well over time and many
advances now we can do that fairly
readily the second challenge with cells
we could not get enough of your cells to
grow outside of your body
over the last 20 years we've basically
tackled that many scientists can now
grow many different types of cells plus
we have stem cells but even now 2011
there's still certain cells that we just
can grow from the patient liver cells
nerve cells pancreatic cells still can
grow them even today and the third
challenge is vascularity the actual
supply of blood to allow those organs or
tissues to survive once we regenerate
them so we can actually use biomaterials
now this is actually biomaterial we can
weave them knit them or we can make them
like you see here this is actually like
a cotton candy machine you saw this
spray going in that was like the fibers
of the cotton candy creating this
structure this tubular eye structure
which is a biomaterial
that we can then use to help your body
regenerate using your very own cells to
do so and that's exactly what we did
here is this actually a patient who
presented with a deceased organ and we
then created one of these smart bomb
materials and we then use that smart
bomb material to replace and repair that
patients structure what we did was we
actually use the bomb material as a
bridge so that the cells in the organ
could walk on that bridge if you will
and help to bridge the gap to regenerate
that tissue and you see that patient now
six months after with an x-ray showing
you the regenerated tissue which is
fully regenerated when you analyze it
under the microscope we can also use
cells alone these are actually cells
that we obtained these are stem cells
that we create from specific sources and
these are we can drive them to become
heart cells and they start beating in
culture so they know what to do the
cells genetically know what to then they
start beating together now today many
clinical trials using different kinds of
stem cells for heart disease so that's
actually now in patients or if we're
going to use larger structures to
replace larger structures we can then
use the patient's own cells or some cell
population and the biomaterials the
scaffolds together so the the concert
Pearse if you do have a deceased or
injured organ we take a very small piece
of that tissue listen half the size of a
postage stamp
we then tease the cells apart we grow
the cells outside the body we then take
a scaffold of our material again looks
very much like a piece of your blouse or
your shirt
we then shape that material and we then
use those cells to coat that material
one layer at a time
very much like baking a layer cake if
you will we then place that in an
oven-like device and we're able to
create that structure and bring it out
this is actually a hard valve that we've
engineered and you can see here we have
the structure of the heart valve and
we've seated that with cells and then we
exercise that you so you see the
leaflets opening and closing of this
heart valve that's currently being used
experimentally to try to get it to to
further studies another technology that
we have used in patients actually
involves bladders we actually take a
very small piece of a bladder from the
patient less than half the size of a
postage stamp
we then grow the cells outside the body
take the scaffold coat the scaffold with
the cells the patient's own cells two
different cell types we then put it in
this oven-like device has the same
conditions as a human body 37 degrees
centigrade 95% oxygen a few weeks later
you have your engineered organ that
we're then able to implant back into the
patient for these specific patients we
actually just suture these materials we
use three-dimensional imaging analysis
but we actually created these
biomaterials by hand but we now have
better ways to create these structures
with the cells we use now some type of
technologies were first solid organs for
example like the liver what we do is we
take discard livers as you know a lot of
organs are actually discarded not used
so we can take these liver structures
which are not going to be used and we
then put them in a washing machine like
structure that will allow the cells to
be washed away two weeks later you have
something that looks like a liver you
can hold it like
to liver but it has no cells it's just a
skeleton of the liver and we then can
Reaper fuse the liver with cells
preserving the blood vessel tree so we
actually profuse first a blood vessel
tree with a patient's own blood vessel
cells and we then infiltrate the
parenchyma with the liver cells and we
now have been able just to show the
creation of human liver tissue just this
past month
using this technology another technology
that we've used it's actually that of
printing this is actually a desktop
inkjet printer but instead of using ink
we're using cells and you can actually
see here the printhead going through and
printing this structure and it takes
about 40 minutes to print this structure
and there's a 3d elevator that then
actually goes down one layer at a time
each time the printhead goes through
then finally you're able to get that
structure out you can pop that structure
out of the printer and implant it and
this is actually a piece of bone that
I'm going to show you in this slide that
was actually created with this desktop
printer and implant it as you see here
that's all new bone that was implanted
using these techniques another more
advanced technology we're looking at
right now our next generation of
technologies are more sophisticated
printers this particular printer with
worthy signing now is actually 1 we
print right on the patient so what you
see here is I know it sounds funny but
that's the way it works cuz in reality
what you want to do is you actually want
to have the patient on the bed with the
wound and you have a scanner basically a
cliff like a flatbed scanner that's what
you see here on the right side you see a
scanner technology that first scans the
wound on the patient and then it comes
back with the print hits actually
printing the layers that you require on
the patient's themselves this is how it
actually works here's a scanner going
through scanning the wound
once it's can't sense information in
layers the correct layers of cells where
they need to be and now you're gonna see
here a demo of is this actually being
in in a in a representative wound and we
actually do this with a gel so that you
can lift the gel material so once those
cells are on the patient they will stick
where they need to be and this is
actually new technology still and their
development we're also working on more
sophisticated printers because in
reality our biggest challenge are the
solid organs I don't know if you realize
this but 90% of the patients and the
transplant list are actually waiting for
a kidney patients are dying every day
because we don't have enough of those
organs to go around so this is more
challenging large organ vascular a lot
of blood vessels supply a lot of cells
present so the strategy here is this is
actually a CT scan an x-ray and we go
layer by layer using computerized
morphometric imaging analysis and 3d
reconstruction to get right down to
those patient's own kidneys we then are
able to actually image those do
360-degree rotation to actually analyze
the kidney and it's full volumetric
characteristics and we then are able to
actually take this information and then
scan this in a printing computerized
form so we go layer by layer through the
organ analyzing each layer as we go
through the organ and we then are able
to send that information as you see here
through the computer and actually design
the organ for the patient this actually
shows the actual printer and this
actually shows that printing in fact we
actually have the printer right here so
I'm in while we've been talking today
we've actually you can actually see the
printer back here in the backstage
that's actually the actual printer right
now and that's been printing this kidney
structure that you see here it takes
about seven hours to print the kidneys
this is about three hours into it now
and dr. Kang's going to walk onstage
right now and we're actually going to
show you one of these kidneys that we
print a little bit earlier today
put a pair of gloves here thank you
go backwards
so these clothes are a little bit small
on me but here it is you can actually
see that kidney as it was printed
earlier today
that's a little bit of consistency to it
this is doctor Kang who's been working
with us in this project and we went a
part of our team thank you dr. Kahn
appreciate it
so is this actually a new generation
this is actually the printer that you
see here on stage and this is actually a
new technologies we're working on now in
reality you know we now have a long
history of doing this I'm going to share
with you a clip in terms of technology
that we have had in patience now for a
while and this is actually a very brief
clip only about 30 seconds of a patient
who actually received an organ was
really sick I could barely get out of
bed I was missing school it was just
pretty much miserable I couldn't you
know go out in play you know basketball
at recess without feeling like I was
gonna pass out when I got back inside it
was I felt so sick I was facing
basically a lifetime of dialysis and I
don't even like to think about what my
life would be like if I was on that so
after the surgery life got a lot better
for me I was able to do more things I
was able to wrestle in high school I
became the captain the team and that was
great I was able to be you know the
normal kid with my friends and because
they use my own cells to you know build
this bladder it's gonna be with me I got
it for life so I'm all set
[Music]
these experiments sometimes work and
it's very cool when they do Luke
come up please
[Music]
so look before last night when's the
last time you saw Tony ten years ago
when I had my surgery and it's really
great to see him
and tell us a little about what you're
doing well right now I'm in college at
the University of Connecticut I'm a
sophomore and studying communications TV
and mass media and basically trying to
live life like a normal kid which I
always wanted growing up but it was hard
to do that when I was born with spina
bifida and my kidneys and bladder
weren't working I went through about 16
surgeries and it seemed impossible to do
that and when I was in kidney failure
when I was ten and this surgery came
along and basically made me who I am
today and saved my life
[Applause]
I'm Tony Dunne hundreds of these what I
know from he's he's working really hard
in his lab and coming up with crazy
stuff I know I was one of first ten
people to have this surgery and when I
was ten I didn't realize how amazing it
was I was a little kid and I was like
yet I'll have that I'll have that
surgery I all I wanted to do is to get
better and I didn't realize how amazing
it really was until now that I'm older
and I see the amazing things that he's
doing when you know you got this call
out of the blue I mean
Tony's really shy and it took a lot of
convincing to get somebody as modest as
tony to allow us to bring Luke so Luke
you go to your communications professors
your major in communications and you've
asked them for permission to come to Ted
which might have a little bit to do with
communications and what was their
reaction most of my professors were all
for it and they said bring pictures and
and you know show me the clips online
and I'm happy for you there are a couple
that were a little stubborn but I had to
talk to him I pulled him aside well it's
an honor to privileged to meet you thank
you so much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
Sharon
that's video on the human Network Cisco
welcome to the human network